[Music]
garlic aliam sabam is a spice plant from
the onion family widely cultivated and
used around the world not only is garlic
an essential ingredient in cooking but
it also offers numerous health benefits
its main component Allison is a sulfur
containing compound with strong
antibacterial and anti-inflammatory
properties additionally garlic is rich
in vitamin C vitamin B6 manganese and
antioxidants which help boost the immune
system support heart health and reduce
cholesterol levels regularly
incorporating garlic into your diet
provides High nutritional value and a
range of health
[Music]
benefits today let's learn how farmers
produce this wonderful spice first is
the step of preparing the soil to grow
garlic the process of preparing the soil
for growing garlic involves clearing the
land of weeds loosening the soil for
better aeration and ensuring proper
drainage organic compost or well- rotted
manure is added to enrich the soil with
nutrients the pH level is adjusted to 6
to 7 for optimal growth creating an
ideal environment for garlic planting
and development
[Music]
[Applause]
manual garlic planting is a process that
requires meticulous care and skill from
Farmers first the soil is cleared
loosened and enriched with organic
fertilizer to provide essential
nutrients for the plants then garlic
cloves are carefully selected typically
choosing large healthy and disease-free
cloves farmers use their hands to create
small holes in the soil placing each
clove with the sprouting end facing
upward and covering it with a thin layer
of soil for protection the spacing
between cloves is usually maintained at
10 to 15 cm to allow for proper growth
this process demands patients to ensure
all cloves are planted evenly and
correctly after planting the soil is
gently watered to make maintain moisture
creating favorable conditions for the
garlic to sprout and
[Music]
[Applause]
grow the mechanized planting of garlic
significantly enhances efficiency and
uniformity in modern agriculture this
process begins with preparing the soil
using Advanced Machinery such as plows
and Harrows to ensure the land is air
rated level and ready for planting
fertilizers are often distributed using
specialized equipment to enrich the soil
with nutrients the garlic planting
machine is then deployed capable of
simultaneously digging small holes
placing garlic cloves and covering them
with soil these machines are designed to
maintain consistent spacing between
cloves typically 10 to 15 cm ensuring
optimal growth conditions some Advanced
models even have adjustable settings to
accommodate different clove sizes and
planting depths a key advantage of
mechanized planting is the time saved a
task that would take Days by hand can
now be completed in hours covering large
Fields efficiently moreover the uniform
planting achieved by machines helps
maximize yield by reducing competition
between plants for nutrients in space
after planting irrigation systems such
as drip or sprinkler systems are used to
provide the necessary moisture for
germination this mechanized approach not
only boosts productivity but also
reduces labor intensive tasks making
garlic cultivation more sustainable and
profitable for farmers
[Music]
[Applause]
the cultivation process for garlic care
is an essential step for Healthy Growth
farmers use tools or cultivators to
loosen the soil around the roots
allowing better aeration and nutrient
absorption this process also helps
remove weeds maintain consistent soil
moisture and ultimately boost the crops
yield
[Music]
harvesting garlic by hand is a
traditional method used by many farmers
especially in areas without access to
Modern Machinery this process begins
when the garlic is fully mature with the
plant's leaves turning yellow and drying
out farmers use a knife or scissors to
cut the roots then pull each garlic bulb
out of the soil care is needed to avoid
bruising or damaging the bulbs once
harvested the garlic is gathered into
small bundles and hung up to dry during
the harvesting process Farmers must
frequently check the garlic to ensure it
is not damaged while this method is time
consuming and labor intensive hand
harvesting helps maintain the Garlic's
quality preventing bruising or spoilage
and also supports the next planting
cycle by preserving the Integrity of the
soil
[Laughter]
[Music]
using machinery for garlic harvesting
saves Time and Labor compared to
traditional methods garlic harvesting
machines are designed to work over large
areas operating quickly and efficiently
The Machine's root cutting components
slice through the soil to sever the
garlic bulbs and then a conveyor or
augur lifts the garlic out of the ground
the machine also separates the garlic
from the roots and soil minimizing
losses and protecting the bulbs from
damage after harvesting the garlic is
sorted and packaged ensuring quality for
Market distribution however using
machines requires a significant initial
investment and depends on factors such
as soil type farming conditions and the
machines precision and operation
[Music]
after harvesting garlic goes through the
Sorting processing and packaging stages
to ensure product quality first the
garlic is sorted by size and quality the
best bulbs which are undamaged and free
from scratches are selected for sale as
Fresh Products while garlic with defects
is processed into dried garlic or other
products like garlic powder or garlic
paste after sorting the garlic is
cleaned to remove remove any remaining
dirt soil or impurities next the garlic
is dried or subjected to a drying
process if necessary finally the garlic
is packaged in suitable materials such
as plastic bags or cardboard boxes
ensuring long-term storage and easy
transportation to
[Music]
[Laughter]
Consumers thank you for watching the
video about the garlic planting and
harvesting process by Farmers we hope
the information shared today has given
you a better understanding of this hard
yet fascinating work don't forget to
like And subscribe to the channel to
stay updated with more useful videos
[Music]